what I believe is that everybody has one
word that defines them it's who you have
always been and who you always will be
your one work and help with all the
major important decisions that you have
to make in your life and in your
business and when you understand what
you're all about and who you truly are
it allows you to then design a life and
design a business that supports you
becoming the best version of yourself
don't ever let somebody tell you you
can't do something
not even me you got a dream
you got to protect it
people can't do something themselves
they want to tell you you can't do it
you want something go get it period
before you can play on this team you owe
me twenty-five hundred push-ups and
1,000 suicide and they must be completed
by Friday what is your deepest fear mr.
Cruz that you're inadequate give up mr.
Cruz go home
I love to laugh oh that long and clear I
love to laugh it's getting worse every
year so the guidebook says that the
routes through here but I know a better
way they cruel away all right all you
gotta remember that everything will be
okay I just think this horse has a lot
of heart he may have been down but he
wasn't out he may have lost a few but he
didn't let it get to him I think we
could all learn a liquor to from this
little guy oh and by the way he doesn't
know he's little he thinks he's the
biggest horse out there see sometimes
when the little guy he doesn't know he's
a little guy he can do great big thing
man shrieks
imagination